the Indian state of Madhya Pradesh
diamond mining has been thriving here
for around 6,000 years diamond
extraction is still the main source of
income in the city of Pune there are no
jewelry shops in these streets but Panna
is a center for smuggling and black
market activities meet human rights
activist Yusuf Bey he works for the
environ extras' tin delhi one of their
focuses is the people who work in
india's diamond mines Yousef bag is a
regular visitor to the diamond mining
areas located some 20 kilometers outside
planet a lot of illegal mining goes on
here the workers here are normally
farmers and day laborers they try to
bolster their monthly income by earning
a few rupees here and there now in the
dog days of summer the river is dry and
mining requires a lot of water
bellick a dance-a-thon is coco teenagers
usually the workers collect soil and
whatever else they can find from the pit
back there they mix it with water and
stamp it with their feet pill it's cool
gravel and diamond sink to the bottom
because they're the heaviest Cangelosi a
la gota de bois can colossal a Buddha
you to panic you madam chef workers then
skim off the upper layers of water soil
with their hands Yahiro Allah let her go
but she may pick up everything leftover
dried in the Sun cannibal day school
paladin Yusuf tells us that this man has
been mining for diamonds for more than
six years despite his age he says it's
enough to get by on and that in the past
he's found some decent sized diamonds
yes Kabu Kabu together here's mr.
diamond Joby diamond if there's a
diamond among the stones the workers
don't have to look too long you see them
immediately because they gleam in the
sunlight give me tomorrow to use me but
there's nothing blooming here today
these young people too are hunting for
diamonds breaking rocks even though it's
more than 40 degrees Celsius in the
shade the youngest of them is 13
his brothers say they're 16 and 21 the
girl does not want to say how old she is
good estimate you'll module comte young
workers often have dust in their lives
that clogs them up and they have serious
trouble breathing
unfortunately they have no health
problem hoppity hop in my daughter I'm
doing this work without breathing masks
and protective clothing is dangerous
Chiappa struck technically but one day
here it's done mine summer camp I was at
a funeral recently I see cattle Moo via
one of the workers in diet of silicosis
dos Gavi Dyson's karate I Yusuf peg has
achieved some small triumphs in his
fight for improved working conditions
for these people the National Human
Rights Commission of India is demanding
that the health of diamond mine workers
be better protected but that's not
enough for use of Baig he estimates that
up to 70% of panas diamonds are
extracted illegally often by children
yogi sargodha brother tear to you is not
at the root of all these problems is
corruption
anyway the government supports a lot of
good projects but the help never gets to
the people who need it
just think the government needs to come
up with a plan to give children here in
education so they can get a decent job
later on finally can lead a good life
yeah we all bought barrio Duke dunno
maybe lexically use of big says the
problem is the lack of schools in the
region
local families have no choice but to
send their children to work in the
diamond fields they need the money to
feed their younger siblings